we're on the road right now and we're in
San Bruno California but today we're
working with Miss Jody because we're
working in Jody's issues about eating
poop and eating at napkins and
everything else we have to make sure
that we actually provide that stool or
feces and order for us to work on the
case you know it's like the only way you
can get rid of fear if you face the fear
the only way you can stop a dog from
eating poop as if it's in front of poop
and so what what what it has worked for
for Miss Jody is actually a banana a
banana for her has become like the
perfect exchange for stool you know so
we weighed the sand yeah we make sure
her mind is very into it please don't
find it this casting or or uh bad taste
but she actually have to come and eat
close to the poop you know so we can
exchange the scent right where the
hurricane is you know I will never do
this set for the case that I'm trying to
change the bad habit of eating poop if
you know poop smells first then there we
go if she's paying attention to the poop
and then I correct and redirect I'm
saying it's something that is healthy
you know instead that eat something that
just came out of your body and so there
you go so now she's stepping away from
the poop and by her stepping away I'm
gonna reward that behavior again now
sterilize the place it's very important
you know we just did face one now we're
doing fish to which is removing the
scent completely you gotta do it again
present the stool one once again I know
for a lot of people this build this
casting before a lot of people's like
finally we're doing an episode where
they address a dog eating poop ignoring
that's what we want
then rewarding that's what she wants
ignoring that's what we want
rewarding that's what she wants
so keep it simple it's two reasons why
adult weed you know stools one is their
bore and the other one their system is
craving a mineral or some kind of
vitamin and so since she chose banana
I believe that potassium in foot is
missing in her body so that's the
exchange we're making so that was a good